hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the terrible old man now
this is based on an HP Lovecraft tale
that I actually have not read but
because I'm not a child at heart I'm
actually a bitter old man who hates the
world and every generation of the divine
doesn't know addressed it country but
also get off my lawn
so what's that limited knowledge I'm
going to do what terrible old people do
best make assumptions on things that I
don't know about so anyway there's this
guy sitting at a bar he's very old
married terribly he's just sitting there
hating life and hating everyone then all
sudden the two pops through the doors
tentacles everywhere it's like a bad
Japanese hentai so anyway the tentacles
go out and kill everyone it doesn't do
anything else to them it just murders
them that's totally fine and then
Cthulhu sits down with you old man
they look each other in the eye they
know they both hate minorities and or I
could just shut up and play the game and
then you can experience what the story
actually is instead of my stupid
rambling oh man so Angela when are we
gonna blow this joint I imagine that
guy's Irish nice little oops
I see we head out tomorrow it's a few
hours drive to Boston how long we
staying there for well I say just a
night we gotta keep moving there Mugsy
and then we're back to Arkham Asylum
that's right I've been talking this guy
up there who might be able to get us
mansion you know see speaking action
look at that Dame over there she got
something going on doesn't she oh that
Dame the hair I think she's got four
boobs going on there I'm not entirely
sure what's happening down there well
incredible incredible Oh
Janek it's sixes annek Janek I'm pretty
sure that's Janek like checketh lockers
rap Czechoslovakia why don't you get
your pasty ass over there and give her
your best line maybe I will maybe I will
and get us some beers while you had it
you still got some cash from the old
broad the other night
yeah I got a few bucks left I don't have
a dime hell that won't no it's so old
she couldn't even get out of the house
to spend her godforsaken dollars better
old manual here spends it on hooch
sorry let me do that right yeah better
old manual here standing on hopes then
let us see here gasm that's for the
other two years he bites it like how my
voice is just changing changing for
every character and every time they
speak well damn right except for that
guy well then get us some beers boy okay
left click to interact right click to
observe for inventory and settings move
cursor to the top screen don't expect me
to keep any voices throughout the
entirety of this ok I'm gonna I'm gonna
say hi to that lady over there yeah are
you doing mmm-hmm say that miss can I
have a word with you leave me alone
great leave me alone [ __ ] Hey no
need for that kind of language lady I'm
merely trying to conversate mmm Oh
conversate elsewhere maybe your mother
oh man all my voices are just gonna be
the worst this entire thing ha try again
Susanne ik soo yourself fine whatever
I'll be back when I get the beers not
the beers like the ring I'm not gonna
get your ring lady you don't deserve it
three beers over here where you guys
from poisoning in move now you goddamn
business just give me some beers is my
bar you watch your manners stranger
folks Knights in King's bow we look
after each other three beers way i order
please Oh oh [ __ ] hold that didn't break
anything we're back I don't know what
happened I'll be dude on my phone ring
okay so it said yeah okay oh it's one of
these steps games armed and take my
money I have exactly two dollars dude
alleyway he may be coming up here Aki I
imagine a guy Rocky
maybe John John Isabella's dryer I'll
have a rule rule up new ones did I make
my batch indeed stay Oh
Dickey eating his dinner yet I swear
whoa your eyes are just a little bit off
there bro
we sat a whole chocolate cake in front
of his face and he didn't so much blank
the boys been affected you're taking him
to see dr. Reeves he'll get to the
bottom of it well he's only been acting
strange this is running with the old
fella vo tonight dear balloon man I
shouldn't let the boy out so late what
happened you know that very old man a
former sea captain of some sort you see
him around town pays for his groceries
in olden rooms I've heard about him yeah
feeble an ancient I hear he ducks that
bottles he has lined up on the table
inside his house how would someone know
that calls and names like Spanish Joe
and mate Ellis this is a lot of very
specific information yeah most peculiar
champs best avoided I think no need
upset such old terrible people something
you need to teach Nicky that boy right
better respect so what happened was
Dicky threw a stone at his window oh
that was in the beginning and the old
man caught him in the act gave him a
good docking to hotbed Dicky won't talk
about what exactly happened oh dear
murder he's a stupid boy you go around
throwing stones and old folks went on
well they aren't gonna be happy no
matter how feeble they are I've told
them means I live in the house for a
month often gonna lose lessons yes right
that's discipline right there he must be
quite a scary sight for a young lad to
face fancy that using gold coins
currency man must be sitting on a
fortune tell me about it I heard it
captain clipper ships in the East
uncountable years back and brought back
gundo dredges from the depth the depth
sorry about the word you busy
mmm I heard a very interesting story
yeah thanks hey boy hey boys muddy hey
Mugsy see we're gonna dam here boys
you're not gonna believe it
you got a date with the broad he wishes
I think we got ourselves a job tonight
yeah well spit it out man I heard these
two chaps speaking about a crazy old man
who lives in town so Richie pays for
things and gold doubloons
hick gold doubloons
yay he's got a room in his house where
he stands they're talking two bottles a
rich and senile old fight ha sounds like
this cinch the cinch let's get down
there tonight and see what he's got to
offer
Noah boy oh boy this should be fun
where's the old man's house then no no
they didn't say find out Susanne ik find
out we may find riches tonight okay
hey hey buddies I'll just eavesdropping
on the conversation hey fellas what was
his old man you guys were talking about
old man around this Park I just have no
he is unbound old man rich [ __ ] blew
what's it do you stranger oh it's still
energy story he sounds like a character
indeed he is shuffles about his King
driving gold all over the show hmm you
said something about bottles sometimes
people see him through his window with
the line of a curious bottle sitting on
a table its bottles some sort of object
inside pendulum some say he's seen been
seemed to chat with him waving his arms
about his tentacles does he cook dodo
I'm afraid the old jabs lost mine too
much time at sea it was a sea captain
yeah though back in the time nobody
remembers rumor has it he spent decades
in the Far East
let's see you guys from Kings boy born
and bred me - where are you from ah
suburb of Boston City boy a cosmopolitan
type yeah yeah he could say that see
well see you know about him you're
asking a lot of questions later hey
they're going to be friendly Brian
trying to progress a store oh yeah I
leave you be
where's the old man live that's hardly
specific
along the coast crumbling ancient pile
it is do one of the old announces king
boy die adventure
we'll see address this isn't just big
hero oh you're thinking of isn't in
ammonia why on earth would you want to
see him for treasure on are you Oh No
good the last thing we need in this town
is outside of bringing her wayward
criminals with them so why do you want
to know his address why should we trust
you out saddest Oh Oh is one of these
actually the right answer are they all
wrong answers ah
we wish to interview in for the local
paper you know cuz I'm not from here yes
what's the name of the local paper Oh
the Kings work no that's too obvious the
telegraph cuz at times the telegraph oh
[ __ ] no you sir pathological liar how
dare you okay reckless guy looks like my
cousin Peter but cousin Peter he ain't
well good observation there dick damn
local goon is one mighty fine-looking
Bard
what you doing in it pit of the town I
don't know yeah maybe the bartender
knows something about the dude what do
you know about the rich old man you know
about a rich old man who lives in town
dare say I do
you must i don't gossip about local zoo
it's a respectable town ter see what can
you tell me about those two guys of
Dubai
hey we're right here mind your business
grated mmm what he's dead will you tell
me about that broad over there you're
working all the time I look like she's
up to me what's your line of work why
don't you ask yourself later let me know
when you want to drink refilled okay so
I know I've already observed her how do
Doug do as if he knows him because maybe
she do know you not you again I'm busy
yeah what you working on apart from
looking pretty
I might not look busy but my job
requires a lot of thinking yeah what's
your vocation I'm a journalist oh me too
I work for the local paper oh we should
have a date ah I'll buy you flowers
whoa big shy why am I talking to you
hey you write for the paper I'm gonna
stop doing the girl boys yes
the Kingsport Daily Star Oh interesting
now get lost before I write an article
about outsiders pissing local women at
bars okay okay put your knickers back on
lady mm-hmm
so now I know the name of the paper now
I can tell them I had the right idea I
just didn't know I liked the boy you
still want his dress how do you know do
you know we can trust you outside
we delivered a local paper Kingsport
Daily Star I got mixed up before we were
through why me huh whatever I don't
remember where I work huh whatever it
don't matter
nonsense it's the truth we are
journalists from Boston we do freelance
work sounds like the old man could give
us great story
imagine the tales he must have tales of
exploration treasure and chivalry you
know what go on I don't really believe
you but this is getting annoying now the
old man lives up on Water Street his
property backs up on the ship Street
near the shore hey I appreciate it boys
boys we got the address good work there
shanty boy where is it back entrance is
on ship Street by the harbor they can't
hear us talking about how we're gonna
rob a Mugen hey we passed that street on
the way here it's just a flu boo shoe
box away Janek you take the car till
then I will go on foot and meet you at
the place it's better if we arrive
separately nice plan let's go boys it's
treasure to be had oh boy I can't wait
oh boy we're not gonna die horribly from
an old man who's really cool
later that evening when the ominous
music starts to play that's women all
right we're here what's the plan boss
it's over you and I will go through this
gate Janek you stand watch okay you two
are gonna die before we do anything
though looks like there's a light on up
there Janek you have a better look we
got to make sure you watching us
well okay I can't see what's the window
I got a spyglass someplace let's dump
late I don't know where hmm don't play
it down for the community believed it
with my spyglass
oh of course my glass would be here
right car key tow mobile okay how about
the trunk yes I am smart I'm so smart
I'm smarty smarty smarty smart fired VAR
o doesn't fit this kid from English
ain't that part apparently mmm the one
of you maybe have the this trunk is
locked by a solitary padlock guys give
me the goddamn key to the trunk you're
holding up the story we need to get
through it because everybody's waiting
for the old man to kill you guys you're
not the key to the trunk do ya I don't
don't tell me you lost the goddamn key
Janek no no see you forgive you for the
drunk how balls I do here we go and
don't tell Sheila or there is any thanks
okay right so now I got the key because
that was a fruitless venture but here we
go almond abscess my lad in a drunk
goody goody gumdrops and they'll be able
to see you I didn't know this game was
gonna be so dialog everybody gets me
flexibility look good rapper always
comes prepared I'm a robber I rob things
I like to steal from old man oh sorry
did I not yell that loud enough for
evidence here spike let's go back to
masks everyone put on your mask when I
have a fun time here tonight oh there we
go okay so now you guys put on your
masks you don't want to be seen put on
your masks only the old man would put on
man I'm not gonna stand here with that
thing on you see what the old man doing
first okay fine
trying to look out for you
that will not achieve anything you will
not achieve anything yeah hey Jerry
talking to his barrels that looks weird
don't look my way old man he's in this
until your fool looks like the easiest
target we ever head good work Janek he
really is talking to a bunch of bottles
long as we're quiet out here shed
notices he is engrossed in his queer
lips that's antic you got our masks in
yeah I knew you didn't want to get him
before but I got a 40 now boss I gotta
put you down he's a mask boss yeah
here's a master robbing people here's
the mask we're gonna put on to robbing
anybody here we're gonna ride with these
masks okay okay get that kid open I got
a crowbar right here just for that have
Bam tink well that was easy
never mind them hey we're in on the
house we're in we're gonna rob them okay
sorry I just had to announce that to
everybody
good work Janek now we're all gonna
speak in hushed whispers okay silver
let's go in how I gotta play it boss
you'll see Doug my dad b2 loquacious
liquid lip lock wishes wow that's a word
that I don't even know concerning his
treasures we may need make him talk
that's it for the gold is even hidden it
he is a scene how's respect he may have
stacks of it piled up all around oh you
didn't have any input on that okay don't
go too hard on the old goat the duo we
need the door the screams of an old man
can be easily muffled so let's shout
about how we're gonna make this old man
scream and steal his gold silver you've
hit the nail on the head Janek wait for
us in the car we shouldn't be back in an
hour at most
sounds like a plan B T Ritchey vici
remember Paige I don't when you're
painting up the me a note I'm done it's
not very subtle
okay is this oh yes they closed the door
behind them for some goddamn reason
Oh Leigh Whannell nothing that probably
explains why my face will probably in
the other side of the bills taking them
so long
I know that's not what's happened they
better not have knocked the old fellow
off I told him I told him I said don't
go through our mail go I told him that I
told him are you they come
oh hey hang on
used in the old man shovel
alright then we're just dead oh god what
happened to us what the hell little
things make considerable excitement in
little towns which is the reason that
Kingsport people talked all that spring
and summer about the three
unidentifiable bodies horribly slashed
as with many cutlasses and horribly
mangled as by the tread of many cruel
boo heels which the tide washed in
oh and some people even spoke of things
as trivial as the deserted motorcar
found on ship Street for certain
especially in human cries probably of a
stray animal or migratory bird heard in
the night by wakeful citizens
but in this idle village gossip the
terrible old man took no interest at all
he was by nature reserve and when one is
aged and feeble ones reserve is doubly
strong besides so ancient a sea captain
must have witnessed scores of things
much more stirring in the far-off days
of his palm remember view
all right then that's the ended oh yeah
that actually ended more abruptly than I
thought it was gonna I mean I knew
something was terrible's gonna happen
when they all decide to go into old
man's house they were gonna rob him I
knew he's gonna kill him dead
who's gonna kill him horribly well that
was likely really cool because HP
Lovecraft is if you don't know HP
Lovecraft HP Lovecraft is like the
grandfather of horror I mean not be
original obviously because no one's
original in anything but people know him
very well for his things like Cthulhu
that's his coming up with and I haven't
actually read a boo he haven't actually
read a lot about you know him and read a
lot of his stuff but even though I
haven't read about it I know a lot about
his stuff what what was that why was
that you're gonna crash oh don't please
no please no you just exited the game if
my recording got [ __ ] up after all
that please please and R okay so I would
recommend actually reading some of his
stuff because it's pretty incredible to
see how the drawing from those ideas
spill into a lot of horror ideas to this
day it's really interesting so give it a
try thank you everybody so much for
watching check out the other scare games
that I've done in the description below
or in the innovations over there and as
always I will see you in
that's be ready to die
you go about you what